le damos la bienvenida a nuestro
compañero de France 24 Rodrigo Sedán
Rodrigo Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros bueno Muchas gracias a ti por
tenerme aquí en este programa y
comenzamos analizando pueblo marcado
digamos territorio ha pisado fuerte
desde temprano con la victoria de la
contrarreloj de ayer pero hasta donde
puedes llegar qué qué cómo se presenta
el resto del giro para él pues es un
poco una incógnita porque benepool dijo
que venía a este giro claramente a
marcar distancias en las contrarrelojes
como ya he hecho en este momento ha
sacado por ejemplo 45 segundos un mar
aproximadamente abrimos roglich el que a
priori debe ser su gran rival tiene 73
kilómetros de contrarrelojes Llanas la
segunda contrarreloj en la novena etapa
veremos cuánto tiempo saca también allí
eumar y la montaña es la gran incógnita
incógnita de renco en el pasado giro no
le fue bien pero también a la vuelta sin
embargo vimos que pudo con los mejores
este año ya sea ya luchado con primos
roglics en la vuelta a Cataluña y la
verdad que ahí el Duelo se lo llevó el
esloveno pero por pocos segundos creo
recordar que fueron apenas seis segundos
los que sacó finalmente la clasificación
general hay que ver porque está
demostrando benet pool que pueden
cualquier tipo de terreno ha ganado la
lija también dos etapas en esa vuelta a
Cataluña frente a primos roglics pese a
perder la general hay que ver él dice
que su gran fuerte lo sabe es la
contrarreloj ya la ha demostrado en la
primera etapa no va a dejar dudas por
ahí hay grandes puertos que no había en
la vuelta a España por encima de 2000
metros tendrá que demostrar si también
ahí está entre los mejores ahora que
mencionas estas tres contrarreloj estos
puertos que no se habían encontrado
anteriormente que podemos destacar de
este trazado con quién se va a encontrar
benepool y y esta rivalidad que va a
mantener con primos
el principal contento bueno como decía
las dos contrarrelojes la que ya
recorrido y la de la novena etapa hay 73
kilómetros de contrarreloj en este giro
de Italia lo cual es bastante frente a
otras ediciones pero es muy importante
ver que ya en la séptima etapa cerrando
la primera semana vamos a tener una gran
etapa de montaña es la que acaba en el
gran saso con una tapa interesante
porque son 40 km en total de subida al
final de la etapa con ese encadenado
calcio gran saso después yo destacaría
la etapa 13 son más de 208 kilómetros de
etapa eumar con el Gran San Bernard la
famosa
chimacopiz en honor a este gran ciclista
italiano y son casi
2500 acaba ese gran server nada 2500
metros es mucha altura no todos los
ciclistas están acostumbrados a llegar
tan alto Tenemos también ese final en
krash Montana pero desde luego la gran
etapa de montaña en este giro va a ser
la etapa 19 la que acaba en las tres
cimas de lavaredo una encima también muy
mítica dentro del giro de Italia muy
famosa dentro de Italia en los plenos
alpes italianos ahí van a tener también
una etapa con
ese final de etapa tiene 18% de desnivel
182 kilómetros y más de 5.000 metros de
desnivel realmente es muchísimo un
encadenado muy potente ya al final del
giro y después de esa etapa en la
vigésima justo antes del final en Roma
vamos a ver una crono escalada de 19
kilómetros 11 kilómetros en total de
subida Quizás es el último empujón de
benepl si ha perdido mucho tiempo dentro
de las etapas de montaña en el pasado
hemos visto a latinoamericanos como
protagonistas egan Bernal caso Richard
carapaz nairo Quintana acá en el giro
que podemos esperar de los
latinoamericanos presentes este año
Bueno creo que será difícil verlos
luchar por la general tenemos nombres
como Rigoberto urán que está con el
education Fer Santiago buitrago yo creo
que deberíamos centrar nuestro foco en
Santiago Si queremos ver una buena
clasificación general latinoamericana es
joven está en un equipo muy potente como
es el barein Victorious y ya demostrado
esta temporada como la anterior que
tiene buenas piernas que puede batirse
con los mejores
Hay que ser claros no está el nivel de
Rango de benevol y de primos roglis pero
creo que incluso le podríamos ver luchar
por alguna etapa si pierde tiempo le
dejan lugar para marcharse en fuga y
bueno la gran baza quizás también para
una posible etapa es alguien del que ya
habías hablado anteriormente Fernando
Gaviria el Sprinter del Movistar que ha
vuelto con esta nueva escuadra ha hecho
ya dos victorias importantes durante la
temporada hay que ver si le veremos es
pintar desde lejos que su especialidad y
hace poco ha demostrado que cuando le va
bien es imbatible también en ese espacio